les spectateurs sont arrivés au
compte-gouttes pas plus de huit
personnes pour cette tournée de sang
sont livrés à domicile ici est la
bibliothèque de lignières chacun profite
de ce petit bonheur franchement on est
bien un
en plein air lignières on va entendre de
jolis their voilà un petit coin de
paradis en août et voudra quand tu
voudras
j'étais la première à m'inscrire ah oui
j'ai trouvé que c'était une idée géniale
surtout pour la bibliothèque
ça fait venir des gens à la bibliothèque
ça ça prouve notre notre lien avec les
bains douches et puis et puis je
trouvais que c'était le moment de faire
plaisir à mes adhérents
[Musique]
après ce concert le duo tourangeau
malachite poursuit sa livraison de
chansons chez des particuliers
l'initiative portée par la scène
musicale des bains-douches rencontre un
franc succès à lignières je suis venu te
dire que je m'en vais adieu créatures
tête de chou avant d'entendre que le
divin fut mais j'avoue j'en ai bavé pas
qu'on est allé à son salon de coiffure
et puis à la massat qui est une
association d'aidé à domicile pour les
personnes âgées
donc à chaque fois on était super bien
accueilli par les lignes à roy keane
était enchanté du concept les bains
douches envisage peut-être une prochaine
livraison de chansons à domicile en mai
juin du coup on espère qu'elle n'aura
pas lieu et qu'il sera possible d'ici là
de retrouver la route des concerts sur
scène vous appelle des bureaux du
bonheur car je sors à l'instant du
ministre
[Musique]